it's getting late everyday we're told we
have all the time in the world
but the reality of it is we don't
at some point we have to make a decision
to write our own history at some point
we have to execute at some point we have
to make our next move
but for most people that next move never
happens you see we don't have time to
wait for our loved ones to apologize we
don't have time to ignore our addictions
[Music]
we don't have time to hold back our true
feelings
[Music]
we keep thinking we have all the time in
the world
[Music]
but it's getting late we think there
will always be another opportunity but
it's getting late our ego tells us we'll
have another chance but the reality is
it's gettin late our time is ticking
and we don't know when it'll run out now
is our time to make our next move
[Music]
before it's too late